it's one thing to see yourself get older
and more and more out of shape but most
of the people are not really never have
been in shape so what does it mean
getting out of shape they've always
looked at the shitty body so therefore
they they can they it gets shitty as
time goes on it's just when you have
been hailed for years as this supreme
body you know and you have the
definition and you see the veins coming
down your abs and you see veins on top
of your chest all you were super I know
you see all this stuff and now then now
you cut and you roll the clock forward
50 years and now you're standing there
and you don't see that anymore so that's
kind of like wow you know I never ever
thought about that when I was like 30
years old or 40 years old that this is
going to happen that you know we one
time we're going to look at this body
and it still looks better than majority
of bodies but I mean it it just sucks